[Laughter]
when it comes to the world of the micro
there's a little bit of something for
everyone do you feel a kinship with
chill blobs that contain hidden depths
well there's plenty of amoeba to
understand
do you love complex choreography well
then you might want to catch a
performance by bass Ilario and if those
don't draw you in there are hunters
living jewels and complicated lifestyles
aplenty to explore for microbiologist
dr. Lynn Margulis the draw with
symbiosis the micro cosmos is made of
many many organisms who don't just
occupy the same space they collaborate
whether it's for protection nutrition or
just some help getting around these
interactions may seem small but their
implications are enormous for all life
on Earth
through the second half of the 20th
century
Margulis is dedication to understanding
symbiosis transformed our understanding
not only of microbes but of ourselves
her legacy is a complicated one rooted
in a stubbornness that at times paid off
in major scientific understanding but
also made her unwilling to acknowledge
the limitations of her work at the core
of her efforts though is a dedication to
microbes and to understanding what they
can teach us about the world lynn
margulis published many books and
articles about microbes for both
academic and general audiences but
perhaps her most impactful work was also
one of her earliest an article published
in 1967 shortly after she began working
in Boston University the paper was
titled on the origin of mitosis cells
and over it's roughly 50 pages Margules
argued that some of the organelles
inside eukaryotes were actually once
long long ago free living prokaryotic
organisms what she was describing was
the theory of endosymbiosis the idea
that symbiosis between one ancient
prokaryote inside another drove the
evolution of eukaryotes we've discussed
endosymbiosis in its own episode and you
may have noted that it plays a recurring
role in the lives of microbes we've
covered this theory is now so well
understood and has so much explanatory
power that at this point it feels like a
thing we've kind of always known but
indeed the battle over the acceptance of
endosymbiotic theory was still going on
during my lifetime I remember being
taught that this was probably a thing
not that it definitely will
in her paper Margules also notes that
she was not the first scientist to
consider the role of symbiosis in
evolution the theory was first proposed
by the Russian botanist Konstantin
sergeyevitch Markovski in 1905 and later
scientists had suggested that the
resemblance they observed between
certain eukaryotic organelles and
certain prokaryotic organisms was more
than just coincidence but while these
bits and pieces of endosymbiotic theory
had been around before her Margulis was
the one who tied them together on the
origins of mitosis cells focuses on
three examples of what Margules thought
were possible endosymbiotic events the
evolution of mitochondria chloroplasts
and flagella from potentially
prokaryotic origins while the paper
didn't describe any experiments of her
own she drew on the works of her
predecessors to provide experimental
evidence for her ideas she also
described predictions for future
experimental results that would support
the theory the result was a paper that
didn't just present an argument it laid
out a multi chapter story of evolution
that drew on their Gulas understanding
of biology and even atmospheric
chemistry to describe how symbiosis may
have driven eukaryotic evolution and how
scientists might be able to verify that
story this paper on the origin of
mitosis cells was rejected more than a
dozen times until it was finally
published in the Journal of theoretical
biology and her paper caused quite a
stir highlighted and debated in both
popular and academic formats some
scientists were just as captivated by
the idea of endosymbiosis as morghulis
was others dismissed her theory outright
in a paper called the
symbiotic origin of mitochondria the
authors wrote that quote while the
symbiotic theory may be aesthetically
pleasing it is not compelling but while
the conversation may have become
contentious Margulis stuck to her theory
to her the notion that these organelles
could have evolved solely through the
accumulation of thousands of mutations
was both improbable and unsupported by
the evidence slow change was part of the
evolutionary story but it was not all of
it and she thought symbiogenesis would
explain these more immense changes that
were necessary to the history of
eukaryotes and so Margules continued to
experiment with her microbes and
investigate the limits of her theory but
so did many others in 1978
Robert mschwartz and Margaret Dayhoff
published origins of prokaryotes
eukaryotes mitochondria and chloroplasts
which was able to experimentally
conclude the prokaryotic origins of
chloroplasts and everyone's favorite
powerhouse the mitochondria this work
was among several that would confirm
that Margulis was right about those two
organelles in particular but as
important in science is what you get
right is what you get wrong no
experimental evidence has turned up to
support Margules theory that the
flagella that helped many eukaryotic
organisms move were originally an
organism of their own she thought they
may originally have been spirochetes but
while flagella x' and other aspects of
her theory have not panned out an
experimental testing Margulis would
continue to defend her ideas lynn
margulis eventually moved to the
University of Massachusetts Amherst
where she would stay until her death in
November 2011 in an interview she gave
to Discover Magazine only if
months before she died she said quote I
don't consider my ideas controversial I
consider them right it's a statement
that may seem admirable when quoted
against the history of endosymbiotic
theory but in the same interview
Margules insisted that aids is not
caused by HIV it's caused by a syphilis
causing spirochete that has somehow been
rendered undetectable to all scientific
and medical scrutiny because of
symbiosis we're not gonna litigate her
statement here because there's no point
in that at the time she gave the
interview there had been decades of
research connecting AIDS to HIV as well
as decades of real-life suffering and
death caused by the virus but this
wasn't the only time Margules engaged
and what some might euphemized as
controversial opinions but that at times
took her fully into conspiracy theories
lynn margulis 'as work was part of a
long history of contrarian ism that
often appeals to us because when they
get things right contrarians push
through established beliefs to reveal
hidden mechanisms of the world but when
they get things wrong they do so at the
expense of scientific rigor intellectual
honesty and just plain old decency and
so it can sometimes be unclear how to
understand and process their work unless
perhaps we take inspiration from
Margules fascination with microbes and
the communities they form just as the
light we shine through our microscope
informs the colors and structures that
shine on the other side our
understanding of the micro cosmos is
shaped by the people who study it their
experience their personalities their
biases these all shape the questions
they ask the ways they ask them and the
conclusions they draw
and so science is at its strongest when
like the symbiotic micro cosmos that
entranced Margulis it is understood not
as the product of a single expert but as
a collective expertise the result of
shared experiences that are constantly
in conversation with each other that is
what made on the origin of mitosis cells
so powerful the way Margulis so
effectively synthesized her ideas with
other scientists work to describe a
whole history of evolution that while
not without its flaws provoked a
dialogue that altered our understanding
of biology and of the history of life on
Earth and this impact makes the
frustrations of her legacy all the more
acute Margulis would continue to draw on
what she learned from the world of
microbes co-authoring a number of books
with her son Dorion Sagan that brought
the wonders of microbial evolution to a
wider audience in one of their books
titled
micro cosmos they wrote quote it is
tempting even for scientists to get
carried away by success stories it's a
sentence that against the backdrop of
both her scientific and unscientific
efforts reminds us that microbes can
teach us a lot about the world but there
is also a limit to what we learn and
often that limit is our own selves
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us thank you as well to
all of the people on the screen right
now those are our patrons on patreon
it's a place you can go to support the
content you love so that it will
continue existing so thanks to them for
helping make this continue to happen
what great folks if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
check out Jam and germs on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]
you